hello my name is Seth Crosby and I am
speaking to you from st. Louis Missouri
and at Washington University my contact
information is at the very bottom of
this screen and any of you that have any
questions or would like to access the
technology I'm going to talk about today
you're most welcome to write I'd like to
thank lab roots for the invitation to
give this talk today I'm going to be
talking about an unusual way that we
have invented to characterize microbiome
samples using multiple 16s hypervariable
regions this was invented by our
director Richard head and our bottle
fermentation Andrew schrieffer who's
since then moved on he's no longer with
us
another co-inventor is one that i'm sure
that many of you will recognize jeff
gordon is also a author on the paper
which is going to be referenced during
this presentation you're most welcome to
read it if you like alright so today i'm
going to talk for about one minute about
our facility and then I'm gonna given a
little maybe another minute or two on
microbiome profiling sort of general
comments and then we'll dive into
talking about 16s sequencing what and
finally most of the talk is going to be
dedicated to M version which is a method
that we have used to characterize 16s
and I'll be talking about a road test we
took with it
where we were comparing it with a very
much used protocol called chyme and much
of that again is captured in the paper
that you're welcome to look at so a
moment about us I started a facility
about eight or nine years ago called the
genome technology access center it was a
cap clia-certified sequencing facility
that was for smaller projects the
McDonald genome Institute has been
resident of Washington University for
decades that was their that much of the
Human Genome Project was done as well as
many other genomes and recently we've
combined into a single facility so we
have tried to keep the best of both of
our qualities and you can learn more
about that word we're so new right now
we're still working on the website and
working on our rebranding and all that
kind of stuff but happy to talk about
that offline with anyone who's
interested this is just a slide my boss
likes me to show just showing that
during and through this process on both
of both of our teams have been
publishing lots of papers or helping
with the publication of Locke's papers
for for the since the inception and we
both occupy buildings so we're all going
to be moving over from cortex into the
into that chocolate covered building so
we'll be physically together in a in a
few months when I was in medical school
when we thought about the critters that
are either on us or inside of us the one
way that we had for characterizing those
was by culturing them and one thing we
knew is that many of the bacteria that
are on us and ants are not culturable so
we could only get sort of a moderate
snapshot of what's going on there
with the advent of high-throughput
next-generation sequencing we started to
be able to rather than culture out of a
specimen we could actually sequence out
of a specimen and this tends to be done
in in two different ways one common way
is shotgun sequencing and this is where
you grind up all the DNA in a specimen
and make it into libraries and sequence
everything that's there so this you'll
get representation of the entire
bacterial genome it's it's can be quite
accurate it's a little bit expensive
because you have to sequence more deeply
in order to be able to get a good
representation of what's there and it
can be a little bit dirtier because not
only are you grinding up often the
bacteria that's present in a specimen
but you're also grinding up the host DNA
as well
which is often not as informative so one
way to address this problem is is rather
than um sequence the entire bacterial
genome scientists a number of years ago
began sequencing just one of the genes
it was the gene that coded for one of
the ribosomes in in bacteria the 16s
ribosomal this is a picture of the
protein of the RNA and the and the
protein bundle together this is the RNA
in 16s and you can see that like all RNA
it assumes a secondary structure of a
lot of stems and a lot of loops this
tends to be relatively similar the
secondary structure is similar from
species to species in the way that's
done is that these stems tend to be
relatively conserved from species to
species these loops however are quite
variable there in fact they're referred
to as hyper variable between species and
these are these can be new species
specific so that if you sequence these
loops you might be able to meet but
you're able to tell what species the the
DNA came from and I want even though
we're talking about ribosomal RNAs this
is what it codes for we are sequencing
the DNA not the RNA were sequencing the
gene that codes for the ribosomal RNA so
what you have is you have a bunch of
these are the stems and in blue and the
the loops in yellow and sorry I've been
using my cursor up until now I forgot
that that doesn't work here so I'm gonna
be a little bit more verbal now the nice
thing you can do here is that you can
you can take advantage of those hi those
conserved regions to divine design
primers for for to do amplicon PCR so
you design primers for the for the blue
domain those tend to work over lots and
lots of species and then you sequence
across the yellow domain which is which
is a specific traditionally the way this
is done is you concentrate on one hyper
variable region it would
quite difficult to be able to try and
compare all the hypervariable regions at
once that would result in in nine
different lists and you wouldn't know
which list was the true one and which
one is not so people will tend to pick
out the hypervariable region they think
is most informative and and will do that
and so you hear you you can see where
were amplifying region v4 sequencing it
and then taking it into bioinformatic
analysis most often people use a program
called chyme which I'll talk about later
to do that by automatic analysis what
I'm going to be talking about today what
we're doing with inversion is we're
doing sort of what I alluded to in the
last slide is we're trying to amplify up
all of the hyper variable regions and
not only are we you can see here not
only are we amplifying up all the hyper
variable regions but in some cases those
those conserved regions aren't quite as
conservatives we hope they would be and
so we will actually design multiple
primers for individual conserved regions
to try and get as much of all of the
hyper variable space as we can there's
one slight modification that's happened
recently to this is we no longer use v9
we don't find that it is particularly
helpful in terms of calling species
level information so you can see there
in the in the little table that i've
drawn there that i've drawn a line
through through v9 another thing you'll
notice is that the amplicon size never
exceeds 300 and the reason that is is
that when we do the sequencing we do
paired-end two by 150 so the most
variable to see is 300 and so we we hold
the amplicons down to 300 bases we use a
high throughput pcr method from a
company called fluid i'm this allows us
to do thousands of PCR reactions in a
single run it's it makes our job much
easier and it also reflects in
lower cost of the of the assay and then
we do next-generation sequencing and the
bioinformatic analysis we're using now
is no longer time but it's M version and
there you can see a reference to the to
the paper that we the first paper that
we published about the subsequently
users have begun using this and so I
believe it's also alluded to a
subsequent publications we find that by
doing by using all of the hyper variable
regions rather than just one or two that
we're able to get more accurate calls
more species level calls rather than
genus level calls unless false positives
and I'll talk about that one I present a
little bit of a little bit of the data
that we generated so we're going to be
looking at the use of M version and the
sensitivity of M version and sometimes
there are students in the audience who
will get bored of my talks and so I try
to make the talk a little bit more
interesting at the same time to remind
them of what positive predictive value
and sensitivity is and I don't think
that any of the talks that I've seen on
lab groups actually involve any games so
it's time we're gonna play a game very
simple game is in the next slide I'm
going to show you a series of circles
I'd like you to count the circles all
the circles that are on the on the slide
except for those little green circles
we're looking at they just gave me a new
template and that contains circles you
don't need to count those but some
circles were very briefly appear on the
screen
I'd like you to count them and then just
sort of normally I have people raise
their hands but just count the number
and then have it mine we'll see how
close you can get to the right number so
watch the screen because it's not going
to be on for more than a second okay
okay how many circles do you think that
you were able to see on the screen just
back then all right
so here's the answer there are six
circles two of them are not exactly
circles those are false positives and in
in my
my own work a false-positive is when you
identify a genus or species of a
bacteria which is not actually present
in your sample and and false positives
by the way is one way that in in this
study and version really stands out and
you'll see that a little bit all right
so that's positive predictive value is
the this is the higher the positive
predictive value the lower the number of
false positives now let's find out how
sensitive everyone in the audience is so
I'm going to do exactly the same thing
just count the circles that you see on
the screen and we'll suppose be back in
a second here goes
okay how many circles did you get and so
often when I give this people tend to be
looking in that rectangle but there's
actually circles that were there that
you didn't identify and these are false
negatives in a microbiome sample these
would be species of bacteria that are
present in the sample that weren't
detected by your assay and that's it
this is a false negative so the positive
predictive value measures the extent of
false positives in the sample the more
false positives which is in the
denominator the lower the positive
predictive value as sensitivity measures
false negatives the more false negatives
in a sample the lower the sensitivity so
in the case of using amplicon sequencing
for microbiome work that the cause of
false positives can it can especially in
the case when you're using a single
hyper variable region rather than all of
them is sometimes even though I've told
you that the hyper variable region is is
can be different from species to species
sometimes especially within the genus
the hyper variable region can be so
similar that the caller will mistake the
species or not be able to identify the
species and will and will provide a
genus rather than the species those are
these are false positives where you're
actually detecting either the wrong
thing or not exactly what you're looking
for the genius isn't exactly a
false-positive but often people who do
this work would rather have
species-level call are that the genus
level call for anyone who's done pcr the
cause of false negatives is relatively
obvious is that sometimes the primers
don't anneal we've already talked about
the fact that some conserved region
primers won't anneal to some conserved
regions sometimes that the resulting
amplitude there so few bacteria that are
present that it's a too little
concentration and it doesn't show up in
the sequence some this is very important
if the if a hyper variable region is not
present in your underlying database in
how you analyze all the hypervariable
regions it's not going to be detected
and there are other reasons why using
amplicon based sequencing and sometimes
result in a false negative which is the
bacteria's presence in the sample which
are not detecting it so I'm going to
talk now about right there where all the
arrows are pointing toward that little
plastic cassette as I said it's made by
a company called fluid I'm and here's
sort of a closer shot of it and what you
do is you in this case it's got 48 wells
on one side and 48 wells on the other
you load your samples onto the left side
and you load your primer pairs onto the
right side and then using microfluidics
the the the sample the samples and
primers are mixed in 30 nano litre
chambers I I don't remember how many
there are but there's 48 by 48 reactions
that are occurring in just a hour or two
and then once these reactions have
finished they go into a single chamber
that where they can be withdrawn and and
their sequence ready they're ready to go
on to the to the hi-c core onto the my C
depending on the number of samples
you're using that's how we decide what
Illumina instrument to use more recently
fluid n came up with a
another system called the Juno in this
case the number of primary pairs you
have our is reduced to one to 24 which
is more than enough for us but what you
get in the exchange for that is you can
run a hundred and ninety two samples at
the same time when we're running this
many samples at one one time and then
sequencing them all in a single run the
cost per sample can get to be quite low
alright so we decided to test this thing
and what we did you can see in the
center there the red and the yellow is
we used the simultaneous use of eight
regions using M version and we compared
that against the gold standard which is
chime and that is how chime is spelled
and in this case we used two regions
regions three and regions for one thing
I want to say about how we configured
chime is we wanted this to be an
apples-to-apples experiment we knew that
by sampling eight regions that the the M
version is extremely sensitive so what
we did was we opened up the chime
thresholds all the way so the chime
sensitivity would be almost as good as
the Amberson sensitivity so what you'll
see in the data when I present it is
that the is that the sensitivity is not
very different but what happens is that
the specificity the positive predictive
value is quite different and you'll see
that in the in some of the data that I
show you what we fed into this
experiment were three different defined
sets or one we got from the government
the BEI set and this is 20 equimolar
it's a cocktail of 20 DNA's from 20
different species in an equimolar
concentration in addition one of our
co-authors jeff gordon provided us some
defined 48 sample sets and in this case
they were equimolar but also he he gave
us the same bacteria in staggered
concentrations the concentrations of
these 48 genomes varied over four orders
of magnitude and the reason he gave us
that is we wanted to find out two things
from M version we wanted to figure out
how specific and sensitive it was we
also wanted to know how well it is at
predicting the abundance of bacteria so
by change by varying the abundance well
this this this will help us for that
problem in addition we got some real
world sets as well these were completely
defined samples from germ-free mice
which had been fed certain previously
identified bacteria and I believe that
there's some samples from human patients
as well so we ran these through time
through inversion and we looked for call
accuracy sensitivity and positive
predictive value and also we looked at
the abundance accuracy and there again
is the reference to the paper if you if
you'd like to look that up so first what
I'd like to do is I'd like to explain
before I get to the data itself I'd like
to explain as best I can I am NOT a
computational biologist but I'll try and
do a good job and by the way if if you
find that my explanation leaves you
still hungry for more please contact me
and I can put you in touch with the
inventor and he can give you a lot more
precise detail than I can about how
inversion works it's a it's kind of a
complicated protocol the idea though is
to be able to simultaneously in parallel
look at all eight hypervariable regions
and use them to be able to determine
make species level call on your data
these these slides are available I
believe if you need them so please don't
try and write down what I'm saying so
what we have here is we have sort of
different going along at the same time
and those those three parallel arrows
represent alignments the the one
parallel arrow is is is l-shaped
upside-down it's it's the
on the on the on the right side but the
their alignments happen three times and
I'll talk about those as I go along but
I'm gonna go ahead and stick with in my
red circle and that red circle is going
to move around the screen and I'm going
to talk about how this works so I'm
gonna talk first about the in silico
side of of what we do this requires no
actual lab work at all this is all being
done computationally and the first step
is a very important step this this
inversion protocol does not work unless
it has a highly curated database so we
take all of the available we look we
start with a public database take take
all of that data and then we basically
get rid of the aspects of that database
which are not useful so for example we
get rid of sequences in the top blue you
can see sequences with genus sequences
with strain but no species sequences
with inconsistent characterizations that
about fungus viruses all that stuff we
try to remove and so for example we
started if in that olive-colored box we
started with the Silva release and we
had about 600,000 16s genes in that and
after cleaning it up we ended up with a
125 species specific 16s sequences and I
told you something that's not quite
right I said we're getting rid of these
annotations that have only genus level I
asked them actually to bring the genus
level back in and so what we do is we
run the protocol we make all the species
level calls that we can make and then we
take what's left any unidentified
amplicons and if we can we go ahead and
run the program again this time using
the genus level so we we do a good job
at identifying species but we don't we
try to leave no stone unturned and we
also do genus level calls on the things
that we can't get species off of so this
is this is just a
picture of the curation of the of our
database so we what we do next now we
have in that in that little cylinder
that says curated 16s database those are
full length 16s genes in that list next
what we do is we determine which
hypervariable regions might be amplified
in our on our lab bench and so we we do
in silico pcr we basically on the
computer we run PCR using a program
called PCR prospector and we determine
which hypervariable regions should get
amplified and this this goes put down to
that cylinder called all predicted
amplicon sequences so now we're not we
don't have full-length 16s anymore now
we have a bunch of predicted amplicons
and what we've done is we filtered away
amplicons which should not appear in the
data the whole the whole thing that
we're doing with m version is that we're
constantly trying to filter away things
which shouldn't be there based on on
different parameters so okay so now
we've we're gonna stop on the in silico
side and we're going to move over to the
to the bench side so as i said before we
do to buy 150 paired-end sequencing we
take we take a whole DNA from our
whatever biospecimen we have we had all
those primers and we end up with a whole
bunch of hyper variable region amplicons
hyper variable region 1 through 8 and
then we what we'll do is we align all of
those amplicons
to the curated full-length database
we're not we're not using alright we're
not using our predicted amplicons yet
we're still up at the top you can see
that first horizontal arrow is to the
full length database and what this does
is this filters away
any species which should not be there
and we end up with what that with a
database called candidate species so
these are these are an pecans from
species which aligned to our highly
curated database what we have in our
candidate species is a whole lot of
false positives or we're only interested
in the gene in in getting rid of this of
the species which should not be there
based on our database so now we have a
list of species that are in our sample
and we have a list of species that might
be in our sample so we need to further
refine this list so now what we do is we
take that list and we this is sort of
the most complicated aspect of inversion
is we we align all of the predicted
amplicons that we got from in silico PCR
with all the amplicons of the of this
species that might be in our samples and
what we're looking at is we're looking
for an pecans which align specifically
to the smallest number of species that
they can so for example in species a and
an ant pecan hyper variable region
number one might might align rather
promiscuously in the data that we
generated on our Illumina instrument but
hyper variable region number two might
align very specifically so in for
species a we're gonna say okay hyper
variable region number two is our best
hyper variable region we're going to
kind of ignore hyper variable region
number one however in species B it could
be that hyper variable region number one
is the is the one that aligns most
specifically whereas hyper variable
region number two is a little bit more
promiscuous so we go through all of the
predicted and pecans and we hybridize
them to all of this of the amp of the
species that might be in our data in
order to determine which amplicon which
predicted and pecan is the most valuable
for any
particular species and this is how we're
able to use all eight hypervariable
regions simultaneously is that we wait
the hypervariable regions using the one
using only the hyper variable region
which is most informative for any
particular species so now we take now we
take all of those the the most valuable
of the predicted amplicons
and we do yet another alignment we go
back to the original data and we align
those the the highly weighted
hypervariable regions to the original
data and this allows us to make the
final species call and also to be able
to predict abundance so I'm going to
show you just a little bit of data it's
much more in the paper if you're if
you're interested so in the top three
scatter plots what we have here is the a
comparison between the predicted
abundance because in all of our defined
samples we knew how much how much of the
bacteria should be in that sample and on
the x-axis is the the actual measured
the the actual amount that we observed
in the samples so inversion is on the
left and then we have the hyper variable
region number three of a wide open chime
very hyper sensitive chime and region
for a wide open chime and what you can
see at first is that for a very abundant
species inversion and chime tend to work
relatively well about as good as the
other the data doesn't look very
different the predictions and the
measurements look relatively close
however as you get into less abundant
species this is where chime becomes less
informative and naturally so because
you're only using a single hyper
variable region if you're using all hi-8
hypervariable regions picking the best
hyper variable region the most
informative one you maintain sensitivity
all the way down across all those orders
of magnitude and the in the bar graphs
below what you see is each triplet of
bars is the left one is
and version the middle one is chime and
the luck and the right one is chime so
and what we're comparing is the first
three bars are true positives the next
three bars are false positives and the
next three bars are false negatives so
the false negatives show us what I
already told you is that the sensitivity
when you open chime up all the way that
chime tends to be about as sensitive as
M version it was able to detect almost
the same number of species as as M
version did however because the
sensitivity is so high in chime as most
of you know when you increase
sensitivity you decrease specificity
that false positive calls were
completely different in chime as
compared to M version so so my where
this very is very sensitive to use all
Aida hypervariable regions it's also
quite specific as well all right so that
is the end of my talk concerning this
new tool called M version which
increases the accuracy of species level
calls when I want to continue to
reiterate that this is not genus species
we can see that the ACT the abundance
estimates are accurate down to a very
low abundance I want to reiterate that
the sort of one of the aspects the
secret sauce of M version is the fact
that we use a highly curated database
the inversion does not work well unless
the databases is curated and I also want
to reiterate the fact that because we're
doing these things in such a high
throughput manner all in the library
prep and the sequencing can go down to
as low as 30 by 30 dollars a sample
which we think is very useful for the 30
shirt's community future directions we'd
like to continue to incorporate other we
have Silva now we'd like to bring
another public data basis to make sure
that our underlying databases as
complete as possible
and we would like to bring in other
primers as well we're missing some
species as indicated in the in the data
that showed you we don't get 100% of the
species and this may be that there are
sticky places in the conserved regions
and we're going to design more primers
to try and cover those in addition we'd
like to be able to do eukaryotic calls
as well we'd like to be able to detect
various fungal species and so this will
be we'll be using the i TS 1 and 2 genes
to do that and i know that all the
questions that you have are in the
future you know when when this is
finally broadcast but I welcome them and
I believe that lab boots is going to
provide you means to communicate with me
and this is a very old slide I just
yesterday delivered that young lady to
the University of Missouri at Columbia
where she's now a freshman so I'm
probably need to get a new slide thank
you very much for your time